nouveau numéro de reporter sur france24
direction le mali où les récents coups
d'état ont sérieusement dégradé la
relation avec la france alliée
historique au point que l'ambassadeur
français vient d'être expulsé et dans
cette région stratégique du sahel on
assiste à un retournement d'alliance les
militaires au pouvoir à bamako
privilégiant désormais le soutien russe
avec notamment la mystérieuse force
wagner constitué de mercenaires russes
en plateau avec nous cyril payen grand
reporter à france 24 bonjour cyril vous
allez en train de de retour du mali dans
votre reportage on va découvrir que les
russes sont bien présents mais
extrêmement furtif pour reprendre une
terminologie militaire en revanche le
sentiment anti français lui éclate au
propre et un jour dans les rues de
bamako oui effectivement et c'est mon
troisième séjour en moins de deux mois
au mali je peux vous dire antoine que ça
accélère jusque là c'était très tangible
et on a changé un peu de de tempo si je
dirais si je puis dire puisqu'il ya des
manifestations hebdomadaires avec un
sentiment effectivement anti politique
française qui est grandissant au profit
évidemment de ce nouvel allié l'allié
russe alors on va découvrir ça dans
votre reportage avec quelques séquences
chocs c'est un reportage que vous avez
tourné avec franck alexandre de rfi
[Musique]
20 janvier 2022 c'est le jour des forces
armées au mali jour de consécration pour
un gouvernement de transition pour les
postes clés sont occupés depuis deux ans
par des officiers putschistes
voici le nouvel homme fort du pays ah si
meego ita un colonel des forces
spéciales de 39 ans porté au pouvoir par
la rue malienne le colonel éternise la
transition et art d'aujourd'hui à
organiser des élections démocratiques
et depuis quelques semaines le mali sous
embargo régional est à la croisée des
chemins pris d'une poussée de fièvre
nationaliste et panafricaniste
les alliés d'hier dont la france qui
déploient des milliers le soldat depuis
près de dix ans dans une force anti
jihadistes sont supplantés au profit des
nouveaux arrivants problème de la
sécurité du mali d'un problème majeur
parce que sans cela tout ne marche pas
la chine bien sûr va travailler dans le
sens de rapprocher les le mali et les
cdo pour trouver un consensus pour
trouver une solution 2 du règlement de
la crise
c'est possible
la délégation russe n'est pas très
loquace mais elle est acclamée par la
foule
[Musique]
vive la lys à vivre un peu du mal
bamako rive droite quartier de kalaban
coura nous sommes dans la maison de
mohamed 30 ans qui est né et a grandi
dans la capitale malienne comme beaucoup
ici mohamed est un ardent supporter du
pouvoir militaire
cela qui est un peu chiant baluch galles
kokalla maïga
c'est l'autre qui est l'autre côté il
s'appelle assimile brut à l'autre que
j'ai de tout ce qui a coûté de la ballue
sadio camarades ces deux personnes qui
me plaît beaucoup les salaires
soutiennent aussi c'est pour cela j'ai
redonné le monde de la nuit les
ministres les auris de la défense
[Musique]
depuis le père fondateur de
l'indépendance
ils ont subi un idéal cet idéal savoir
l'émancipation des peuples africains
moi je m'inscris dans cette optique
pour pouvoir mieux aborder son combat et
voir l'épanouissement général des
peuples africains bon c'est que nous
avons vu avec la france de 2012 dao
jaune ça fait neuf ans ils sont ici avec
quels résultats
tous les jours c'est des pics et des
villages qui sont brûlés de femmes
enceintes assassinés brûlés vifs des
enfants est tué ça pousse dans nous
voulons diversifier nos partenariats
mais nous sommes contre l'ingérence ce
qu'on veut pas que quelqu'un d'autre
peut que ce soit la france n'est autre
pays viennent nous imposer leur foi
nous sommes le 22 janvier et c'est une
nouvelle journée de mobilisation dans
les rues de bamako une semaine
auparavant des centaines de milliers de
maliens ont répondu à l'appel du pouvoir
et sont descendus dans les rues du pays
pour dénoncer les sanctions régional qui
frappe le pays
ce nouveau rassemblement est organisé
par le groupe et rigolo debout sur les
remparts
le noyau dur des jeunesses nationalistes
malienne la manifestation tourne
rapidement à la diatribe anti françaises
à
[Musique]
bakou apa
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
je rencontre un sentiment de fierté
sentiment de patriotisme qui m'amène à
nîmes comme ça vraiment je suis pas mal
hier et des peuples africains
[Applaudissements]
sow
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le cortège de plusieurs milliers de
manifestants pendant de longues heures
faire le tour de la ville en gonflant
ses rangs
[Musique]
cette manifestation a été une réussite
totale en affaires
[Musique]
à toute allure le mali pana samedi au
caire jeudi encore merci
[Musique]
à robin li aujourd'hui sont les voix qui
s'élèvent contre ces mouvements
souverainistes
c'est qu'ils jurent que par la russie
pour moi ces soldes et maliennes
manipuler
sont vraiment manipuler j'en veux pour
preuve les autorités actuelles là on de
placer les débats sont allés si
l'intérêt des manipulations des débats
c'est juste le respect du délai de la
transition
ce sont ces manipulations là qui pousse
certains à soutenir les autorités de la
transition pour exiger l arrivée des
mercenaires ou non de la russie
le jeune militaire qui n'aiment pas
aller au front combattre les terroristes
profitent a souvent des blocages pour
essayer de renverser le régime
démocratiquement élu et une fois arrivés
au pouvoir ils n'hésiteront pas à tisser
à faire venir des mercenaires
combattre les terroristes
ces mercenaires ce sont les
paramilitaires du groupe wagner bras
armé de l' influence russe à l'étranger
syrie libye mozambique centrafrique et
depuis peu mali la question de la
présence militaire russe est à bout ce
lanceur d'alert prend d'énormes risques
en nous emmenant vers l'aéroport
militaire de bamako où les forces russes
se réinstaller
à l'aéroport il ya une zone réservée au
contingent russe venu il a pas très
longtemps il ya la mini sma il ya
également les femmes et à des routes
quintette est fermé
samedi le poids qu on ne boit pas le
contingent russe
il semble que les maliens sont divisés
sur le sujet
il ya beaucoup de partenaires qu'ils
n'accepteront jamais que les
paramilitaires viennent à combattre à
leurs côtés il ya cette raison pour
laquelle les lampes a beaucoup profité
ils savent aussi que c'est à magna
héritier du premier président modibo
keita sont également en tant que je
pourrai
la défense de l'intégrité du territoire
dob normalement arriver ni une femme
là où vous voyez les installations des
antennes c'est là où ils le sont
cela ou de charge il ya maintenant
l'homme au moment des décharges et il
faut en toute discrétion
c'est dans cette base que seraient
regroupés les forces russes wagner ou
forces conventionnelles coopérant le
doute persiste
quoi qu'il en soit nous n'irons pas plus
loin
sur fond de guerre froide virtuel la
présence de la ministre russe est
largement entretenue dans la guerre
informationnelle que se livrent les
puissances d'hier et d'aujourd'hui comme
en attestent ses vidéos de propagande
qui pullulent sur les réseaux sociaux
malien si on vous place au sommet du
monde le groupe paramilitaire russe
wagner compte intervenir sur le sol
malien avec quatre mille cinq cents âmes
qui seront déployés à partir du 11
novembre prochain dans la bande sahélo
saharienne et dont la mission consistera
à lutter contre le terrorisme et à
soutenir les forces réglementaire du
mali et de ses voisins à faire face aux
défis sécuritaires dans la région et les
images qui sont moins que jude law ne
sont pas vraies
ces images on n'intéressait pas posée
alou diallo et ses confrères blogueurs
passent leurs journées à traquer les uns
fox qui parasitent la toile et polarise
dangereusement le débat public au mali
le coup d'état l'avait demandé me tell
qui son couloir avec ses nationalisme en
juillet mais qui voilà qui prend de la
force et cette tension automatique entre
la junte militaire au mali et le tour
était française cette piste de mala au
palace un défaut d'information dans
chaque partie et c'est vraiment de
d'avoir mon client avec avec l est
direction cathy la ville garnison des
hauteurs de bamako c'est ici qu'ont
souvent été fomenté les nombreux putschs
au mali le dernier en date n'échappe pas
à la règle
mohamed est un fils et frère de soldat
cathy est le berceau de sa famille
[Musique]
cette collaboration avec la russie
vraiment que pendant dix ans après il ya
l'armée française et toutes les autres
forces qui sont ici le résultat c'est
massa n'a rien donné et en quelques mois
de l'arrivée des russes les femmes en
ont commencé à avoir des résultats sur
l'intérêt un peu partout frémin qui
veulent la collaboration entre le mali
et la kz et puis elle dit aussi que
vraiment assis mais elle a tout leur
soutien
et comment tu arrives à rester quand
même assez modérée parce que tu vas tout
le monde est un peu énervé au mali en ce
moment au burkina faso en guinée et toi
tu arrives à être modérée qu'est ce qui
fait la différence avec toi
a dit comprendre que la vie politique
française et la population française en
sciences de la vie politique malien
malienne social malienne il ya une
petite différence c'est que les gens
n'arrivent pas à comprendre c'est là tu
n'as même la prostitution
voilà malentendu confusion mais aussi
des pays au bord de la rupture alors que
le mali et ses nouveaux alliés pousse la
france vers la sortie cette nouvelle
voie malienne qui se propage chaque jour
un peu plus au sahel est aussi un saut
dans l'inconnu pour des millions
d'habitants d'afrique de l'ouest
voilà pour ce reportage signé cyril
payen qui est avec nous en plateau on
l'a vu cyril dans votre reportage
sentiment anti-français qui grossit avec
des affiches d'ailleurs on en découvre
certaines ici extrêmement violente
comment on travaille à bamako
aujourd'hui quand on est journaliste
français le mali est un contexte un peu
particulier par extension le sahel
puisque c'est une zone d'influencé
oublié où on est très très proche
d'ailleurs le le moto la bassée on est
ensemble il est vrai quand on voit
macron assassin mais même nos médias
france médias monté sur un départ à
nancy était sur des panneaux de manière
récurrente on son nous sommes des
visages connus ou au mali et il est vrai
que quand on est on peut le voir
maintenant quand on est stigmatisée ça
nous touche nous mêmes et ça c'est un
peu nouveau dans cette manière de
travailler pour autant encore une fois
même si on voit des débordements pour
l'instant j'en veux pour preuve que la
localité d'expats les 7500 expatriés ne
sont pas menacés il y a quelque chose
d'une chape de plomb une propagande bien
établie mais on ne passe on n'en passe
pas on ne passe pas le cap des mots si
je puis dire en tout cas c'est un climat
nouveau délétère et qui va croissant
parce que ce genre de manifestation
maintenant vont être organisées presque
de manière hebdomadaire avec l'aval du
pouvoir en place le gouvernement de
transition est attisée aussi par des des
réseaux sociaux où circulent beaucoup de
beaucoup d'informations alors le le
gouvernement de transition incarné par
ce cet aréopage de jeunes colonel
putschiste a lancé une sorte de fuite en
avant avec cette cet accord en tout cas
avec des forces étrangères et on parle
des russes notamment quels scénarios
possibles à l'avenir très difficile
c'est effectivement une fuite en avant
parce qu'on se demande comment les
salaires vont être payés je rappelle que
le mali aujourd'hui et au ban des
nations régionales la cedeao
l'association économique d'afrique de
l'ouest a coupé a mis sous embargo ce
pays quand une bulle la communauté
internationale également réclamé des
élections qui n'arrive jamais et on se
demande comment économiquement
socialement ça va tenir mais cette fuite
en avant c'est aussi un élan
souverainiste populiste panafricaniste
six convois dans d'autres pays où il ya
des jeunes colonel des lissiers du même
rang de la même je dirais du même âge
qui prennent le pouvoir le burkina faso
la guinée
donc tout ça est inquiétant parce que
c'est vrai que si on peut respecter
cette notion aux nationalistes c'est un
saut dans l'inconnu qui va impliquer des
millions de gens est en tout cas
clairement aujourd'hui c'est la france
qui est le bouc émissaire idéal puisque
c'est un partenaire traditionnel très
ancien mais qui est accusé de tous les
maux de na pas avoir pas avoir réglé le
problème djihadistes on est impliqué
pour une très grosse opération
extérieure française militaire depuis
dix ans barkan qui se redéfinit un petit
peu tard la porte de sortie pour
l'instant c'est peut-être les français
on le saura peut-être prochainement
peut-être que les français vont
simplement partir mais pourquoi une
autre solution militaire russe ou pas
est extrêmement difficile ce qui se
passe sur le sur le terrain cyril payen
grand reporter à france 24 merci
beaucoup cyril d'être venu en plateau
c'est la fin de cette émission merci à
vous de l'avoir suivi on se retrouve la
semaine prochaine pour un nouveau numéro
de reporter
[Musique]